[Music]
good morning Hank it's Monday November
5th today's video comes in 10 parts 10
parts are you crazy
I know it's madness but the good news is
that each part is going to be extremely
short like what we just did what you
mean like this back and forth yeah
exactly that was part 1 wow you didn't
even introduce the part you just BAM
went right into it I know it could keep
talking about what a great trick it was
but I got to move on to part 2 part 2
Hank thanks to you and dad for that
video you dug up of me at the Orange
County public school author Awards it
was quite interesting for me to see the
way I responded to the first compliment
my writing ever received from a peer and
while I'm tempted to agree with you that
that moment represented the first time I
realized that my writing could connect
me to other people into the world I
think it's far more likely that that was
the first moment I ever realized that a
girl might for even one second like me
part 3 Pakistan listen up General
Musharraf because I know you watched the
show you're pissing me off stop it part
4 Paper Towns Hank the ball that is
Paper Towns is back in the court that is
my house which means that for the next
week or so I'm going to be editing like
14 hours a day and it's going to be very
stressful
so anyway heck I feel like I should tell
you that this week's video blogs are
gonna be kind of like Alberto Contador
at the Tour de France which is to say
that I'm gonna go really fast and I
might have to use steroids to do it part
5 earworms Hank you know sometimes a
tune or a lyric from a song will get
stuck in your head like you know like I
need Harry Potter like a Grindle Oh
needs water and as Saturday approaches
my need grows like that well lately I've
been having poetry ear worms like this
from Walt Whitman has anyone supposed it
is lucky to be born
well I hasten to tell him or her that it
is just as lucky to die and I know it
part six nerdfighter like Hank I have
great news we've raised enough money
through the generosity of many many
nerdfighters that now we can bring our
secret sibling and her secret
nerdfighter boy together so that their
awesome can collide and cause an awesome
mushroom cloud that will spread awesome
fallout all throughout the world
Hank even though they've basically been
outed in my pants I'm still not going to
say their names until they told me it's
okay but I have to tell you they are so
cute
Hank they're so cute that they could
beat any of the puppies or KITT
zhan cute with Chris part seven Pakistan
again I mean seriously George Bush have
you ever liked a leader of a country who
turned out not to be a total jackass
like remember when you first met with
lad Amir Putin and you said that you
could see into his soul you saw that it
was a good soul excellent call George
Bush and then do you remember all the
wonderful things you said about
Musharraf it's almost like you have
really questionable judgment part aid
one more thing about Pakistan I gotta
know if you can tell that I'm really mad
about what's happening in Pakistan right
now do you remember in 2003 and 2004 and
2005 when President Bush would say over
and over and over again
democracy is on the march um where is it
marching to because it's not marching to
Pakistan and it's not marching to Russia
it's not marching to Nepal it's not
marching to China it's not marching to
Saudi Arabia it's not marching to Libya
or Kuwait Roman or Kotter it's not
marching to Venezuela in fact if you do
a count you might find out that there if
you were genuinely democratic countries
today than there were when democracy
started marching Hank maybe democracy is
marching to Mars which I'm sure is great
for the Martians but it's a disaster for
us Hank we have got to get democracy off
the march immediately part 9 the outro
Hank it looks like the people of
Pakistan are going to be less free
tomorrow than they are today
just as they are less free today than
they were yesterday I don't look forward
to seeing that tomorrow but I do look
forward to seeing you
part 10 the scavenger hunt Hank
nerdfighters have found Clues all over
the United States
they found a dollar bill in Indianapolis
a dollar bill in Englewood Florida and a
note just outside of Chicago
they've D anagram doll the anagrams in
the notes and they have found the video
that we've hit for them now we're going
to calm down for a day and just chat